that passcode is the
devil it can be God sometimes or it can
be the devil I'm here because I got too
carried away and sometimes when you do
that you end up places like
this Aaron Johnson is due to spend the
next several years at this high security
prison because he stole hundreds of
iPhones and from them hundreds of
thousands of dollars he exploited a
vulnerability in apple software the same
vulnerability I've been investigating
for the last year he grabbed the phone
and then disappeared along with others
Johnson seen here in red would Target
people in and around bars in Minneapolis
to get their phones and their passcodes
I'll just watch and put it in how many
numbers six rarely I get four digits in
cities across the country thieves are
using the iPhone passcode to get into
stolen phones and loot their victim's
bank accounts and money apps and lock
them out of their Apple accounts
sometimes for good following our
investigation into these widespread
crimes Apple created new security
software but you'll have to turn on the
stolen device protection setting and
even then some loopholes Remain the
biggest loophole
you that's why I sat down with Johnson
to learn how we tricked victims and
turned Apple security vulnerability into
a lucrative
business how did you get involved with
stealing phones so at first I just
started pickpocketing phones I didn't
get the passcode or nothing I just got
the phone I was homeless I didn't have
nothing started having kids and needed
money so I couldn't really find a job
let's say it's Friday night we meet at a
bar I have an iPhone 15 Pro Max what
happens I say I have the drugs they say
they want the drugs
and I tell them take my information down
the whole time I don't have any drugs so
as soon as the phone's in my hand I just
ask them what's the code or I watch them
put it in before they give it to me and
then I kind of just talk about other
things is there an age of person you're
looking for when you're out College
because they're more partying and they
already drunk and don't know what's
going on for real I interviewed a number
of Johnson's victims all men under 30 I
was approached by by two men who seemed
very ecstatic some told me Johnson
approached them offering drugs I
definitely had cocaine they were like do
you want to buy some and I was like no
others told me Johnson would say he was
a rapper and wanted to add them on
Snapchat just a Snapchat like that's
just that just seems normal when I open
up the phone and I hand it to him to put
in I lock the phone and then I tell him
that it's locked or or something wrong
with your phone it locked on me then
that's when I okay no problem 266 4
something something or they just do it
for me you ever videotape them yeah
videotaped a lot of numbers never did
this people say Hey you took my phone
yeah but by that time it's already I
don't have it no more so what you want
who has it whoever I pass it to this
wasn't a one-man job a police
investigation alleged that Johnson
worked with others according to his
arrest warrant he used trickery and
violence to get the phones Johnson who's
Now 26 pled guilty to racketeering and
was sentenced to 94 months in prison
you've got the phone you've got the
passcode what do you do next it's kind
of like a like a bank robbery you got to
be quick you got to go to the settings
and go to the iCloud click reset
password and put the six-digit code in
and make my own password and then I turn
on find my iPhone and then that
completely locks him out the phone this
was the bit that was so crazy to me when
I first started reporting on this crime
with just the passcode to an iPhone a
thief can change someone's Apple ID
password and do a host of other things
to your account and phone how fast were
you changing Apple ID passwords faster
than you could say super Calif
fragilistic asid docious 5 10 seconds I
got to that fast where I can do it just
right there so why are you doing this so
fast so that I can take control and they
don't have access to it anymore you got
to beat the mice to the cheese with the
passcode Johnson removed the owner's
face from face ID and enrolled his own
making it easier to gain access to saved
passwords to bank apps this is my phone
right you've gotten to my settings where
are you going from here so then I go add
my face on there on the face ID
verification now when you got your face
on there you got the key to everything
what you opening things that people
thought were safe like
savings checkings cryptocurrency apps
venmo venmo PayPal yeah you don't need
face for none of that that's kind of
little money I'm trying to take as much
as I can if Johnson couldn't unlock the
apps with his face he'd look elsewhere
on the phone I just go through their
notes and password to everything is in
there social security number everything
while victims were sleeping Johnson
would be draining money from their bank
accounts before 5:00 a.m. I would have
everything transferred out of the bank
but then if some people have like credit
line or something that's when I go
shopping with it go get you know nice
stuff go to Nordstrom by using Apple pay
yeah just by
beeping my face on there so all I got to
do is put my face on it then beep and I
can swipe for thousands of dollars
clothes shoes you know all type of stuff
kid stuff there was one more trick to
this scheme after stealing the money
John would erase the iPhone yes using
the passcode and password and sell it
was there an average selling price of an
iPhone that you would sell if it's a
iPhone 14 pro Max with one
tbte I probably get like $900 Johnson
said he' typically look for those iPhone
Pros with their Telltale three cameras
for a 128 GB or 256 GB iPhone Pro or Pro
Max he'd get about
$650 for a regular non-pro iPhone he'd
get $300 to
$400 probably get like five to 10 phones
a night so 10 20 30 30 phones from
Friday to Sunday he said he can make up
to $20,000 a weekend just from selling
the phones and while he did steal some
Android phones there's more value to the
iPhone but here's the kicker Johnson was
using stolen Apple products and their
Apple pay function to buy more Apple
products it was an extensive scheme of
profiting off of Apple's vulnerabilities
and products I go to Target probably get
like three four iPad Pros mhm yeah brand
new in the pack like 1,200 1300 each
then I'll sell it with iPhones you were
using the Apple products to get cash
yeah exactly what I was doing do you
think Apple should be doing more yes I
think Apple should do more to protect
people but first they got to hire me I'm
just playing well Apple has done more
but now you need to do more too a week
after I visited Johnson Apple answered
our months of reporting on these crimes
with the stolen device protection
setting when it's available in iOS 17.3
it will be off by default if you don't
turn it on all of Johnson's tricks will
still work if you do turn it on it adds
a line of defense to your phone when
you're away from home or work a thief
would need your face or fingerprint scan
to change an Apple ID password then
they'd need to wait an hour and then
again they would need your Biometrics
same goes for adding a new face ID and
disabling find my iPhone to access save
passwords a thief would need your
Biometrics still some apps like venmo
are vulnerable and using Apple pay to
buy things would still work also don't
store your passwords in the notes app
everything that you can ever imagine
it's in the notes or with in the photos
plus you should just create a stronger
passcode one that uses letters and
numbers and of course don't give your
passcode out I mean watch your
surroundings stay on top of it that's
all according to the warrant Johnson's
group was thought to have stolen
$300,000 Johnson says that the grand
total was probably somewhere between $1
and $2
million do you ever wish you didn't know
this
trick I mean I wish I would have not
been so greedy and just got what I got
and changed my life I
truly am sorry for all the
people that I stole from and probably
ruin your
life but I just felt like my life was
ruined and I had nowhere else to go when
you get out going to forget about this
trick it's going to be new tricks out
but I don't want no parts of
it I'm I'm just going to be do better
with myself my life for my
[Music]
kids